-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
-Thank you for having me.
-Welcome to the show.
-And Michael.
-Great to see you guys.
Sean, you actually made your
network TV debut on
"Late Night,"
when I hosted "Late Night."
-I did. Right here.
So, February 5, 2010.
-Oh, really?
You remember the date?
-I'm very good with dates.
-How do you remember the date?
-So, two days later,
on February 7, 2010,
the New Orleans Saints, hometown
team, won the Super Bowl.
-Ah. That's big deal.
-So my appearance on
"Late Night"
was immediately forgotten
by everyone in my life,
everyone in my hometown.
I stood right there and, at the
end of my set, went, "Who dat?"
The battle cry of
the New Orleans Saints.
No one remembered.
-Oh, my God.
Well, here you are now.
-It's great to be back.
-Michael, it's always
good to see you, buddy.
"SNL" was great, by the way,
with Steve Martin last weekend
and Martin Short.
-Oh, man, wasn't that crazy?
-That was a great episode.
This week, you have
Austin Butler and Lizzo.
-Yes.
-That's going to be a good show.
-It's the Christmas show.
It's the most important one.
-It's a big deal.
-Yeah, it's the one.
-You produced Sean's special,
and I want to get into that.
But, first, I have to talk
about something that I saw.
I follow you on Instagram.
-Oh, I'm very sorry.
-And -- No, no.
You always make me laugh.
But I want to clarify something
that happened
between you and Questlove.
-Oh, yeah.
We should talk about this.
-So, the other week --
So, SZA was the musical guest
on "SNL," okay?
So, here's what Michael posted.
-Yeah.
-It says...
-That's right. I did.
Sounds strange, but it happened.
-Natural.
Obviously.
-She meant business.
-And, of course...
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, that's -- So, it's a
rock, paper, scissors joke,
a long walk.
-It also really happened.
-Yeah, right.
So...
[ Laughter ]
What a long walk
for that punch line,
which I love and I laughed at.
And I know you delete
your Instagrams
so they don't live forever.
-Yeah.
-But Questlove posted it
to preserve it.
-Yes.
-Did you know
that Quest did that?
-I had no idea.
What happened was, I found out
that they covered this story on
"The Breakfast Club"
as actual gossip.
And they attached
Questlove's name to it,
and I'm like, "What?!
When did this happen?"
-Look at this.
This is all the headlines.
This is real. Look at these.
"SZA arm-wrestled The Rock
at 'SNL.'
Questlove says, 'True story.'"
-Wait. What?!
-Questlove --
-Wait. They think I did that?
-Yeah.
-They think,
like, you witnessed it.
-Oh, no, I was
preserving your joke.
-No, no, no.
This is why I delete everything,
because people think it's real.
-I just wanted to make
the record straight.
Yeah, that did not happen.
-Your posts are like the McRib.
You know?
-They're here for --
-They're here for a minute,
and then it's gone.
-Yeah, just gone, yeah.
-When are they coming back?
-Yeah. When did you decide to do
a special together?
Michael, you produced it.
-Well, Sean is being a little
bit humble right now,
but he always kind of had this
reputation in New York City.
Anybody that follows
New York City comedy,
he always had this reputation of
being one of the killers,
like, just one of the absolute
beasts at it, you know?
So everyone kind of knew of
him that maybe even
he didn't know back,
and I was one of those people.
-You can tell how comfortable
I am right now
having Michael say all this.
Even though I appreciate it,
yeah, that -- Thank you.
-But I always asked him --
I was like,
"Man, I would love to do
a special with you."
And he started producing --
You already produced one with
800 Pound Gorilla, right?
-800 Pound Gorilla, yeah.
-And he was like,
"Man, I would love to, you know,
have you kind of,
you know, walk this in."
And I was absolutely on board.
-Is that right?
Is that what you --
-This feels like we're married.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Is that how you remember it?
-I mean, it's --
Eh, you know, close.
-How do you remember it?
-See, I remember more
we would --
We had this conversation
like a few years ago.
I was like,
"I want to do a special."
And Michael -- We were --
You know,
we're at the Comedy Cellar.
You're having some drinks.
You're having some fun.
And, suddenly,
he's like, "I'm doing it.
I'm producing your special."
I say, "Great. Let's do it.
I'm doing it and I'm running
the hour next week at the --
Come see it."
And he didn't show up.
But busy man, you know?
I understood.
-Yeah.
-No big deal.
And then I see him
like a month or two later.
He's like, "Don't worry.
I want to do it.
I want to produce it."
I'm like, "You got --
Let's do it."
And then a pandemic hits, right?
-Wow.
-Oh, right. Yeah.
-And then, you know,
that happens.
-Alright, so that happened, too.
-You kinda forget
every prior obligation you had
up until that point.
And then, finally,
we just did it.
800 Pound Gorilla came to me
and said, "Let's do it."
I said, "Absolutely."
And then, one night,
I get a text from my manager,
who's like, "Hey,
I'm talking with Michael's reps.
He's in.
He wants to produce it."
I'm so excited.
And then I see you
a couple months later,
and you're like,
"I'm mad at you."
You remember any of this?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-You were like,
"I'm mad at you, man.
You're doing this --
I hear you're doing a special.
I want to produce it."
I'm like, "You are.
I've been talking to
your entire --"
-Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, yeah.
-"I've been talking
to your team.
You're producing this."
-Yeah.
"You're taking this.
We're going to do it."
And you were like, "Oh, yep.
Sorry. Done.
What do you want?"
-I said, "Streaming."
And you go, "Pssh! Got it."
And then you did it.
-That's --
I forgot all about that.
-Yeah.
-I know you got to film it --
What's the beautiful theater?
-Oh, Tipitina's in New Orleans.
-Tipitina's.
-A classic, old -- It's, like,
an amazing music venue
in the city.
And I wanted to shoot it
in the city
where you knew it was in
New Orleans without --
You know,
I didn't want to put like,
"Hey, look,
a Mardi Gras float going by,"
or, like --
-You don't want to be too --
-No.
Like, "Hey, look,
we're all eating po' boys,
and, uh-oh,
a special is about to happen."
-Yeah, yeah,
you don't want to do that.
You want to keep it subtle.
-Right, right.
-But even your accent.
Did you have more of
a New Orleans accent
before you were in the city?
-Oh, so, I often get inquired.
People ask, where is my
New Orleans accent?
It's -- The thing
you're thinking about
that most people
think about when it comes to
a New Orleans accent, that like,
"Oh, you better watch out.
They got -- We found a
12-foot gator on the lawn,
cut him open.
His belly full of live crawdads.
They was in there hiding.
-That's exactly right.
That's New Orleans.
-"Ooh, man, the other day, I got
pulled over by the sheriff,
and he was in a boat.
I said, 'Sheriff, how you got
that boat on land?'
He said, 'I ain't on land, boy.
You got your damn truck
in the bayou again.'"
-Yeah, exactly right.
That's exactly right.
That's what we like.
-Right.
-That's a more
Western Louisiana.
Like, that's Lafayette,
you know, Thibodaux.
-I was about to throw
beads at you.
-I think, like,
a true New Orleans accent
sounds far more
like an actual --
like a New York accent.
-Really?
-Like, if you took, like,
that New York guy who's like,
"Hey, you know, move it.
What are you doing?
Get out of my way.
Where you going?
What do you want?
Will you get out of my face?
What do you want from me?
I'm going my way. You go yours.
What?"
Take that guy and give him
a few Valium, right?
And once those Valium take
effect, now you got, like,
a legit New Orleans accent.
Just sort of like,
"Where you going?
Ah, that's crazy. I'll come."
You know? "What you --"
Like, a true New Orleans
accent sounds far more like
a sedated firefighter
from Brooklyn.
"Oh, they got a fire over there?
Aw, that's crazy, dude.
Oh, I got to fight it?
Yeah, that's a'ight."
-I want to show a clip.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
By the way, I also want to say,
I love the length
of this comedy special.
I appreciate that as a fan of
comedy specials and comedians.
This is like an hour and a half.
-Hour and 27 minutes,
but there's a narrative.
There's a story.
-That's some quality comedy
you can watch right now.
Stream on Peacock right now.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Sean's special,
"Number One."
Take a look.
-My parents were born
the same year,
next door to one another
in the Lower Ninth.
They grew up
knowing each other since birth
and they started dating
when they were like 14, okay?
And it ruined me. Destroyed me.
Their relationship
turned me into
a little romance bitch,
you know?
Just weeping all the time.
Like a fatter version of Cupid,
just firing hot-dog darts
that would just
deflect off of every woman
I fell in love with
every 48 hours.
You understand?
You think being ghosted is bad?
Try not getting a response to
hand-written poetry
over and over again.
-That's exactly right.
You think that's hard?
Michael Che, Sean Patton,
everybody.
"Sean Patton: Number One" is
streaming right now on Peacock.